today we're talking about a new series
on multi-cloud growing your career and
security
I'm Daryl and welcome to this week in
Cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
there's never been a better time to talk
about multi-cloud it is not simply about
lifting and shifting old it
infrastructure to a cloud for cost
savings and convenience
it's about driving digital
transformation by inventing new ways to
accomplish business objectives using the
best of breed services from different
Cloud providers
that's why we're excited to introduce
our new multi-cloud mindset series
featuring engaging live conversations
with top experts about multi-cloud
topics that takes place on Twitter
spaces once every two weeks you can jump
into the 15-minute q a to get answers to
your most pressing questions and listen
to episodes later offline for up to 30
days after we chat
around the world organizations across
multiple Industries are in the midst of
digitally transforming their businesses
and Ukrainian businesses are no
different they are looking for new ways
to survive grow and Thrive digitally in
an unstable and uncertain environment
that's one of the reasons we are
launching the grow your career with
Google Cloud program for ukrainians
looking to develop world-class expertise
with practical skills in Cloud to fuel
the rapid digital transformation of
Ukraine and invest in its future with
expanded job opportunities for it
professionals
Google Cloud's organization or org
policy service is one of our most
dramatic features but it is often
underappreciated by security teams it
provides for a separation of Duties by
focusing on what users can do unless the
administrator set restrictions on
specific resources to determine how they
can be configured
this drives defense in depth from
configuration errors as well as defense
in depth from attacks learn more on the
blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud